so let's kind of take this one piece at
a time so I think there's a lot of
people who have no clue about the
Treasury markets about how the auctions
work and why that's so important maybe
explain how do these auctions work and
then also why they're so crucial right
we talked about kind of funding for the
government etc if you can explain both
how the auctions work and then why
that's the thing to pay attention to I
think a lot of people kind of get it a
little bit better
yeah the auctions are really the nerve
center of capital markets and like I
said the Treasury bond US Treasury is
considered so-called risk-free asset I
put that deliberately in air quotes but
but there are a number of so-called
primary dealers that are required to
step up and bid on those auctions and
then they turn around and resell the
Treasuries but effectively they're
guaranteeing that the Treasury
Treasuries get sold but to the extent
that the banks have challenges with with
their own funding keep in mind that's
sort of a loop right because the banks
actually need those Treasuries at the
same time for them to get funding in the
repo market so I probably won't go into
more details than that but let's step
back and understand about the auctions
specifically but but the big picture is
what does it mean the US Treasury is
essentially the reserve asset of the
securities industry just like the so
called monetary base is the reserve
asset of the traditional banking
industry and what happens is that a huge
amount of debt gets piled on on top of
those so-called reserve assets again
Treasuries in the securities industry
and monetary base in the banking sector
most of you if you studied economics in
school understand how fractional reserve
banking works that you take a dollar of
so-called monetary base and then
typically the banks issue out ten
dollars worth of loans through
fractional reserve multipliers that you
turn one dollar of monetary base into
ten dollars of credit that's the way the
traditional banking system works but
that's not where most of the credit has
been issued in the economy or in the
financial system in the last couple of
decades most of it has been issued in
the so-called shadow banking system
which is really the securities markets
where
Treasury bonds which are io u--'s of the
US government just like our analogous to
the monetary base being an IOU of the
Federal Reserve again both of these I
owe use they're a really important point
we're gonna pile even more IOUs on top
of that and there's actually a lot more
leverage than ten to one in the in the
securities industry and so when you
think about the fact that a lot more
leverage got piled on those Treasuries
that the next question is alright what
happens if we get into a deleveraging
environment you usually see a run to to
safety and and again the risk-free
risk-free in quote air quotes asset is
is the Treasury bond and we see the rush
to safety we certainly saw that Treasury
yields collapsed which meant that the
price went up his yield and a price move
in opposite directions
you saw them hit record lows across the
entire interest rate curve US Treasury
interest rate curve this past week and
so there was a rush to rush to quality
but then you start to get the the
reality that in fact actually liquidity
has kind of disappeared from these
markets and it took a Fed bazooka to get
a 30-year Treasury auction done the
auction was done at a relatively good
yield it was only a couple of basis
points wide but but the what's called
the bid to cover the it the internals of
that auction were really challenging so
it just is it it's indicative that we're
in a pretty severe dislocation in the
financial markets even more so in fixed
income than in equities got it and so
when you say that that auction was in
trouble and the Fed steps in with you
know the 1.5 trillion dollar
announcement explain kind of the
mechanisms of they say hey we're going
to inject this liquidity but what
exactly is happening there from a
mechanism standpoint so that people
understand kind of how they quote say
yeah so so the the injection of
liquidity is literally injecting
reserves into the banking system
injecting cash into the banking system
the Fed's balance sheet increases some
people call that printing money that's a
that's an outdated term but it's still a
term that describes what's going on
you're literally creating the feds
writing a cheque on itself they're
creating
assets out of thin air and expanding
their balance sheet and in the last
crisis in 2008 the Fed's balance sheet
was about 800 million and then it
swelled up to well over 4 trillion and
then the Fed started to reduce its
balance sheets it's through through as
it was raising interest rates and and
letting some of the assets that it had
purchased run off but now that's reverse
course and now the feds increasing its
balance sheet again and and so from the
Fed perspective were north of four
trillion I think around 4.2 4.3 trillion
of fed balance sheet right now again up
from 800 million in the last financial
crisis one of the analysts who I must
take my hat off to Doug Nolan who really
got this whole thing right and has been
chronicling what was coming in the in
the credit markets he predicted that the
Fed's balance sheet would swell to 10
trillion in this next crisis which i
think is here he predicted that by the
way he's been predicting that all along
so that's not a new prediction and and
at the time and she thought last fall
when he published it most recently it
struck me as way too low and in fact
actually I think it's going to turn out
to be way too low so everyone from my
perspective and again I should step back
and say none of this is advice you're
getting what you're paying for here this
is just one person's perspective and you
can't rely on it but hopefully it'll
just help make you think that's the only
thing I want to want and what would like
for you all to take away from this is
just one person's perspective to help
make you think it's just it's a
different perspective than you're gonna
read in the mainstream press but anyway
coming back to that is the 10 trillion
dollar number that much you know I back
it back in last fall I think a lot of
people were shocked by that prediction
and at the time I said no way that's way
too low the Fed's balance sheet is
actually going to be a it end up being a
lot bigger than that now what's the
impact it means that the banking system
is very liquid from the traditional
banking system they've got all kinds of
cash the problem is that cash is in the
wrong place it doesn't help the
securities markets because the banking
industry and the securities industry are
pretty separate there are a few of the
gigantic banks the money center banks
that are in both sides there are
traditional banks and their and their
Securities Dealers primary dealers that
have that handle Treasury auctions for
the US Treasury and but but even there
they they actually the balance sheets
are typically not even in the same legal
entity so there's some there's that the
cash is going into the traditional
banking industry but not into the
securities industry and and that's part
of the reason why you see these
dislocations that don't totally make
sense but in fact actually if you
understand the plumbing it does make
sense yeah and so help us understand
right when we talk about this kind of
expansion of the balance sheet one of
the things that I saw on Twitter
recently is I think Ben Bernanke on a 60
minutes episode somebody said to him you
know what exactly like where is this
money coming from are using taxpayer
money and he you know kind of
nonchalantly said no we just go in and
we just edit the account number so then
he talked a little bit about that
expansion of balance sheets and the fact
that the number really is backed by
nothing and is kind of at will can be
expanded without any kind of logic
behind well you just laid out exactly
the way it works the Fed is literally
writing a check on itself it's the only
institution only bank it's illegal it's
legally a bank it's the only bank that's
allowed to do that to literally create
money out of thin air and then it's it's
monetary base like I said gets
multiplied by other banks who are
allowed to create a different type of
money out of thin air but all this is
coming out of thin air
now if what's the what's the real impact
of it it's all debt it's right it's all
an IOU actually in fact even the dollar
is an IOU everything's an IOU go look at
the dollar in your wallet if you have
one it says Federal Reserve Note pay to
the order of it is it is a debt
instrument the dollar itself is a debt
instrument so everything everything is
an IOU piled on top of an IOU piled on
top of an IOU that's a really important
point I think to some for some listeners
that's going to be news
most of you probably understand that the
the banking system is an IOU we don't
legally own the deposits in our bank
account that's a promise to pay from our
banks so effectively we've lent them the
dollars we've deposited in the bank the
piece that very few people understand in
my experience though is that the same is
true in the securities industry we think
we own the shares in our brokerage
account in fact we don't they are IOUs
the same way that the deposits in our
bank account are IOUs we're actually
taking an obligation from our
counterparty to deliver us the asset and
they have an obligation from a different
counterparty to deliver them the asset
and they have an obligation from a
different counterparty to deliver them
the asset and there's a huge daisy chain
of IOUs in the securities and banking
industries respectively they both work
the same way and so but at the end of
the day the bottom remember I talked
about the base asset in each of the two
types of financial industries the
banking industry and the securities
industry the base asset in and of itself
is an IOU to your point